Salut. Aujourd'hui je suis à Lyon
et je suis à l'espace Gerson.
Et nous allons commencer le deuxième opus
de la série "Expérience Mentale".
Mais le problème c'est : quand je fais
une vidéo "Expérience Mentale",
pour lancer... puisque forcément c'est en deux temps :
Collecte de des données, et
Interprétation des données.
Donc le premier temps, la collecte des données,
c'est un peu fadasse comme vidéo ..
C'est pour ça que je vous réserve un bonus
à la fin de cette vidéo :
c'est un extrait du spectacle !
[Musique Générique]
Je vais garder la surprise sur l'objectif
réel de l'expérience.
Parce que, si je vous annonçais tout,
ça fausserait les résultats.
Ça, je vous l'expliquerai une fois
qu'on aura fini la collecte des données.
Tu vois le genre ?
Je vais vous demander de répondre
à quelques questions.
Mais pas dans l'espace commentaires !
Parce que si vous le faites dans
l'espace commentaires,
il va se passer deux choses :
La première c'est que ça va influencer
le choix des autres,
de ceux qui vont lire...
Et la deuxième c'est que, pour récupérer
les données, c'est une tannée !
Donc je crée un Google Form et vous
allez répondre via ce Google Form.
Mais où est le Google Form ?!
Dans la description...
bien sûr !
Ce qu'on va faire là, même si vous ne
connaissez pas encore le but,
sachez que ça n'a jamais été fait
réellement,
ça n'a jamais été fait
de cette forme là,
à cette échelle là...
La première question c'est :
Quel est votre âge moyen ?
C'est à dire que,
si vous avez 27 ans,
vous pouvez mettre 30.
Arrondir, un petit peu, au dessus.
Si vous avez 12 ans, mettez 10.
Si vous avez 32 ans,
mettez 30 également.
Deuxième question :
Quel est votre film préféré ?
Troisième question, et je vous demanderais
de répondre spontanément,
donc la réponse qui va vous venir
maintenant à l'esprit,
c'est ABSOLUMENT la réponse que vous
devrez mettre dans le formulaire.
Le formulaire, à partir de maintenant,
ne doit pas avoir de réflexion
mais on cherche à avoir les réponses
spontanées !
Le plus spontané possible.
Citez moi le nom d'un Super Héros.
Et c'est CE Super Héros là
que vous marquez dans le Google Form.
Ne changez pas.
Nouvelle question spontanée
à laquelle vous ne devez pas réfléchir
et répondre quand je claque des doigts :
Vous allez me donner un nombre,
entre 0 et 100,
n'importe lequel,
maintenant !
Nouvelle question : vous allez me donner
n'importe quelle note de musique
entre Do, Ré, Mi, Fa, Sol, La, Si,
maintenant.
Nouvelle question : donnez moi le nom de
n'importe quelle grande capitale.
Et dernière question ;
S'il vous plaît, toujours en réponse spontanée
sinon, ça n'a pas d'intérêt pour le test ;
Donnez moi le nom d'un monument célèbre,
maintenant, le premier qui vous vient à l'esprit.
Merci d'avoir joué le jeu.
Ça c'est super.
Donc, en bonus de cette vidéo
puisque l'expérience mentale
en elle-même,
la collecte des données
c'est pas ouf non plus !
Je vous mets un extrait de l'intro
du spectacle de ce soir.
Intro qui va bientôt changer dans le spectacle,
puisque Mental Rodage
c'est le spectacle qui change
en permanence
pour aboutir au nouveau spectacle.
C'est parti.
Merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo.
[Fab] J'aimerais que tu imagines
un poster devant toi,
ou un écran de cinéma,
où tu vas mettre une image
de ton film préféré.
Si c'est trop compliqué d'avoir
une image animée,
tu prends une image fixe,
qui te convient, du film,
et tu la mets devant toi,
comme s'il y avait un poster de cette image.
[Fab] C'est possible que tu le fasses?
[Spec] Ouais.
[Fab] Ok. Donc là... là c'est fait ?
[Spec] Ouais c'est bon, ouais.
[Fab] Ok. Alors, regarde l'image
comme si elle était bien devant toi.
Tu as pris une image de n'importe où
dans le film, c'est ça ?
[Spec - Acquiesçant] Hmm
[Fab] Ok.
Tu regardes cette image de haut en bas
et de gauche à droite.
[Fab] D'accord.  Vous avez vu,
[Rires dans la salle]
les yeux ne sont pas allés
très très haut...
Alors ça, ça veut dire que ça se passe
à l'intérieur en général...
C'est à l'intérieur ?
Ce n'est pas en extérieur ?
[Spec] Oui.
[Fab] Oui ? D'accord. Ok.
[Rires]
[Fab] Est-ce que tu peux regarder le personnage
principal ou les personnages principaux,
s'il y en a plusieurs...
[Fab] D'accord. Ok. Il y avait une différence
de taille ; c'est des hommes ?
[Fab] C'est ça ?
D'accord.
[Fab] Plusieurs hommes, ensemble...
A l'hôtel...
[Rires]
[Fab] Est-ce que tu peux regarder un petit peu
l'endroit où ils sont, la décoration, les meubles,
ce genre de choses... ?
[Fab] Sur l'image ! Sur ton image,
mentalement.
En face de toi.
D'accord. Il n'y a rien, ok.
[Eclats de rires]
[Fab - caricaturant le spect.]  Ben tu sais, dans une chambre, il n'y a pas grand chose...
[Fab] Voilà... Je ne regarde pas
les mêmes films...
Ok.
Je vais encore te demander
un tout petit effort,
tu vas aller au tout début
du film,
que je vois le générique s'afficher.
Ce n'est pas possible !
On ne peut pas faire ça !
[Rires]
Tu vas juste t'imaginer
le titre du film entre mes mains.
Si c'est trop gros pour entrer entre mes mains,
tu réduits la taille de la police.
Mais tu fais tenir ça entre mes mains.
[Rires]
Et tu le lis.
Mentalement.
Comme s'il était là,
de gauche à droite.
Tac, tac, tac.
D'accord.
Article. Deux mots.
C'est ça ?
[Spec] Non.
[Fab] Il y a plus de mots que ça,
ou moins de mots que ça ?
[Spec] Ah ! Article et deux mots ?
[Fab] Ouais.
[Spec] Si, c'est ça.
[Eclats de rires]
[Fab] Ce n'est pas grave...
[Spec] C'est ça, c'est ça.
[Fab] Euh... Ok. Je commence à avoir
une bonne idée.
Alors, tu sais quoi, Paul,
je vais dire le...
ton film.
Le film que tu avais là.
Si je me trompe,
tu ne me fais pas de cadeau.
Tu dis : Non, ce n'est pas ça.
Si ça ressemble, mais que ce n'est
pas exactement ça,
tu me dis : Non, ce n'est pas ça,
tu t'es trompé.
Je ne veux pas qu'il y ait
d'ambiguïté avec ça.
Si... si je me trompe,
ce n'est pas grave.
Enfin : ce n'est pas grave...
Moi ça va me saouler de me tromper !
Hein ?!
[Rires]
Mais, ce n'est pas de ta faute.
C'est que de la mienne.
Je pense que le film que tu es
en train de visualiser,
avec tous les éléments que j'ai,
je dirais que c'est "La ligne verte".
C'est correct ?
[Paul - riant de surprise] Oui.
[Fab] Oui ?! Merci beaucoup Paul !
[Rires et applaudissements]
Je vous fais la fin d'ici, donc je ne sais pas
si j'ai réussi à faire mon intro ce soir,
parce qu'il y a des soirs
c'est plus dur que d'autres...
En tout cas, moi, je vous remercie
d'avoir participé à la collecte des données.
C'est cool.
Dans quelques semaines, je reviens avec vous
avec les résultats.
Je vous explique à quoi ça sert, etc...
Comme d'habitude, pensez à liker
cette vidéo, vraiment,
pensez à vous abonner,
si ce n'est pas encore fait.
Et à très bientôt,
début de semaine prochaine.
Ciao.
[Musique générique de fin]